hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle now in 2009
an austrian artist named michael
marcovici presented the world the most
intrinsically valuable art piece to have
ever been created the installation was
named very adequately 1 billion dollars
and it represents 12 standard pallets on
which buckets and bundles of hundred
dollar bills are stacked that amount of
money would probably just about fit onto
a 20-foot shipping container but why am
i telling you about this well according
to the us identity theft report losses
from identity theft amounted to 712
billion last year alone that is 700
containers filled to the brim with
hundred-dollar bills to transport them
you'd probably need an entire
handy-sized vessel and today i'm going
to teach you how to keep your money off
of that ship and safe in your pocket
[Music]
so back to the us identity theft report
according to ita group's researchers the
coronavirus pandemic has directly led to
a two-fold increase in personal data
fraud now i suppose a significant
increase in the number of unemployed
people and additional social programs to
support the population attracted the
attention of cyber criminals here people
who lost their jobs were happy to grab
attractive opportunities to earn some
money off the internet and equally there
were many who applied for stimulus
checks online
and here many were taken advantage of
and were subsequently exposed to the
most common kind of cyber criminal scam
[Music]
according to statistics 34 of cases of
personal data theft are related to the
substitution of a social security number
for my fellow non-american viewers uh
social security number is a nine-digit
unique number that every u.s citizen has
this number is used for tax accounting
and pension calculations ssns will be
required when applying for a new job and
they'll also be required at the bank
when opening a new account applying for
a loan or renting a house if you live in
the uk like me it's basically a national
insurance number now the widespread use
of social security numbers for identity
verification has a downside scammers can
actually find out your number by digging
through your trash or stealing mail from
your mailbox bank statements drafts of
contracts and landlords notes could
quite easily uncover your social
security number or your national
insurance number and therefore security
experts like me recommend that you
should always carefully destroy any
ssn or ni related papers
so why are scammers hunting you for your
social security number or national
insurance number well firstly it's so
that scammers can change their identity
or the identity of their paying customer
to hide closet skeletons from a would-be
employer
imagine that joe valeriovich blogs had a
criminal record for financial crimes
it's unlikely that he'd get a job at
barclays banking even as a cleaner but
using your ssn an attacker might be able
to get a decent position and possibly
commit new crimes using it it's like
looking in a mirror only
not
now that exact thing was done by anthony
lamar taylor in 1997 he stole tiger
woods's social security number and for
more than a year the famous golfer did
not even suspect that the frauds to
manage to issue a copy of his driver's
license and get a 17 000 loan now these
loans are obviously not paid and this
attracted the attention of tiger woods
accountant the police subsequently
quickly found the fraudster and now he
will spend the next 200 years behind
[Music]
[Applause]
bars prevent the repetition of such a
story with your social security number
close access to your credit report if
criminal tries to get a new card or open
a new account using your number he or
she has not a chance because no bank
will deal with the person without a
credit report now when you decide to get
a new loan yourself you'll have no
problems opening access to your report a
stolen social security number can ruin
your relationship with the irs in the
best case scenario the fraudsters
employer is going to report this
person's income to the internal revenue
service when you file your tax return
irs employees will have questions about
why you hid part of your income you also
have to prove that a completely
different person used your number in the
worst case scenario the fraudster may
actually try to defraud the irs
themselves for example they might try to
issue a fake income declaration on your
behalf now the trick here is to get the
government to reimburse fictitious
income tax to receive the payment
they'll have to use an account that has
no ties to you whatsoever but it will be
extremely difficult for you to prove
that you're not involved in the scam in
any way shape or form to protect
yourself from snn related tax fraud file
your income declaration as early as
possible this basically increases the
likelihood that fraudster will attract
attention by specifying a number that's
well already been used and if you
receive a letter from the irs with
questions about earnings that you did
not receive do not delay the matter
immediately report suspicions of social
security number theft
in 2020 the use of stolen ssns to
receive unemployment benefits has become
well especially popular i'd say and
sometimes scammers manage to arrange
such payments in several states at once
to notice such a crime in time you ought
to regularly check the operations on
your insurance account so make sure to
do that and most importantly never ever
give out your ssn to suspicious sites
scammers often try to fish out your
number by promising a huge prize to a
random visitor or forcing you to specify
it to receive i don't know a valuable
gift right or ticket of some kind
congratulations you won congratulations
you won congratulations also try not to
use banking websites either they're
relatively easy to fake and they can
actually be used to get your personal
data use mobile apps instead do not
store a photo or a scan of your ssn card
or national insurance number on social
networks let me explain why social
networks are much easier to hack than
your bank account right and if your
account is hacked the number may
actually get onto the black market
treat the data of your newborn children
in the same way in 2017 alone more than
a million american families have been
confronted with child identity theft i
didn't theft
cost them 540 million dollars in direct
losses for example there's this case
with kimberley reed from seattle and she
was surprised to learn that her
two-year-old son is not only taking his
first steps but is also earning a decent
amount of money at least the irs
certainly has questions about the kids
income tax i'm only 12.
i can't be held legally responsible hmm
good point unfortunately in almost 20 of
cases here children become victims of
their parents guardians or relatives and
about 60 of children who have become
victims of fraud know the perpetrators
often children
trustfully disclose their data to
friends on social networks or sometimes
they're lured by cunning or the threat
of violence by familiar teenagers right
by the way uh 987 65
4320 that's my social security number no
that's your pin number no my pin number
is 3674.
bingo digitalization of school and
medical documents has become another
channel for the leakage of such data
as the result of a negligent attitude to
information security child
identification data often gets leaked to
the world wide web so to protect your
child teach him or her about the real
dangers of the online jungle and do that
from an early age do not forbid online
communication but explain in detail that
the strange attention of a network
friend can actually threaten them
unpleasant surprises can also be waiting
for you in the hospital
the theft of medical identity is
something you should be concerned about
and it's becoming more and more popular
moreover in this case it's not just your
wallet that's a steak it's your health
too let me explain medical identity
theft is the use of someone else's
identity to basically obtain medical
services the danger to your health is
that diagnoses extracts and the results
of examinations of fraudster can get
into your medical history and this
happened to a new yorker actually named
june smith and one day she visited a
doctor and he stunned her with this
incredible news tests showed that june
was pregnant however june was in no
hurry to please her husband tom with
this news the fact of the matter is that
they were both over 70 years old there
could be no question of a pregnancy
whatsoever now medicare specialists
joined this investigation quite quickly
and they found out that tens of
thousands of dollars when to pay for
non-existent doctors in fictional
hospitals now to detect this kind of
fraud in time i would suggest carefully
monitoring your medical history any
incomprehensible tests that show up or
requests from other hospitals or serious
reason to check your health insurance
similarly you can actually protect
yourself from
surely you've heard stories more than
once about how fraudsters can make large
purchases using someone else's credit
card they're my new i don't need a job i
don't need my parents i've got great
boots boots how'd you pay for them
a credit card and who pays for that
um my oh this type of fraud appeared
simultaneously with the plastic cards
themselves only then not computers but
phones were used for remote purchases
and while the cardholder would dictate
his or her number and expiration date
the attacker could actually eavesdrop
and record them for his own shopping
now fake websites are more often than
not used to steal other people's data
right they can simulate a bank an online
store or even an online auction in any
case the mechanism is pretty much the
same you enter your car details without
suspecting that you're on a fraudulent
website copying design and basic
functionalities is not really difficult
at all it just remains to register a
domain that is similar to the domain of
the site that you're interested in
now here similar letters actually play
into the hands of the scammers and this
is very interesting right because in the
browser address bar it's very difficult
to distinguish certain letters from
others for instance a lowercase l
looks like an uppercase i and an
uppercase o looks like a zero so this is
why the domain
aloha.us
is easy to replace with well
aloha.us now this is the chef's choice
when it comes to the menu of the
hackerhouse grill however
if people used to send fake links via
email well now they're increasingly
using sms push notifications and short
messages and in them they mask fake
addresses using link shortening services
therefore always double check such links
or better yet open a new browser tab and
type in the address manually so as to
not confuse the letters but only really
inexperienced scanners debit money
directly from the account and it's quite
easy to detect especially if you set up
notifications for your account some
scammers may actually start with small
deposits
if you don't notice the appearance of a
couple of extra dollars then you clearly
don't keep track of your account and
this is a good signal to then start
withdrawing more money
therefore do not rejoice in unexpected
money an incomprehensible transfer is a
good reason to actually contact the
bank's security service okay right
here's a fun story for you all
i was on a drunken night out about a
year ago and i suddenly remembered it
was my friend joe's birthday now for
some reason i thought it'd be a really
good idea to buy him 10 000 class d
instagram followers now this was funny
for me because these are the kind of
accounts that you don't want following
you they have no followers they have
some random name right and their profile
is a mix of capture images
now being drunk i didn't realize that
the site to which i was in putting my
car details wasn't that kosher
but who cares right i was paying 20 quid
to make my mate famous and piss him off
a bit or so i thought and over the next
month i started getting mysterious
withdrawals appear
from my account and after a bit of
research i found that the account that
was taking my money was the same one to
which i had paid for those instagram
followers so card blocked police
contacted yada yada but i don't know at
least joe had fun deleting all of those
unsavory instagram accounts from his
page but look obviously this was at the
hand of an amateur
serious attackers more likely to use
your data to open a new account now the
trouble is sometimes criminals can
actually copy your identity without the
use of your social security number or if
you're in the uk your national insurance
number now i'm talking about something
called social media impersonation
okay so scammers can actually create a
fake profile of you on one of the social
networks and then they can use that to
deceive your family of friends for
example you probably have an account on
i don't know instagram or facebook what
about tick tock or likey
okay but then there's wechat clubhouse
caffeine or vero and for us oldies
there's linkedin and myspace there are
really too many of these social networks
to count and your shadow double could
really appear on any of them
scammers only really need to copy the
public data that's available on your
main profile and just wait until one of
your real acquaintances asks to be
friends and the more you write about
yourself somewhere on the internet well
the more realistic their fake portrait
of you can seem now i say that because a
few years ago the story of clint
eastwood's son caught my attention a
network fraudster using the fake profile
of scott eastwood tricked a gullible fan
who agreed to help the son of the
celebrity buy a plot of land in poland
fake scott came up with an exciting
story including fraudulent lawyers and
bank accounts in the usa and even sent
the gullible woman a copy of his
passport all of this was in pursuit of
grand total of 150 000 us dollars and as
soon as the money appears in the account
of the fraudster eastwood's son vanished
into thin air damn it we're dying here
teleported to counteract such attempts
don't be lazy make sure to create a
legitimate profile on all the popular
social networks and claim your unique
username on places such as facebook and
instagram remember these are services
that only allow one there is only one
brad jay peak use identical profile
photos across the board and leave a link
to your main place of virtual residence
for close friends and family but even
such methods will not protect you
against the new fashion in online fraud
[Music]
now with such deception scammers combine
pieces of your real data with fictional
ones and this allows them to create a
reliable but independent digital
identity
now let's say you're building this
fraudulent avatar it could effectively
combine your real ssn number a portrait
that is generated using this person does
not exist in your network and maybe some
credit card data that's been stolen from
a canadian student and then sold on the
dark web now there are also services on
the web that help generate reliable
phone numbers for this avatar addresses
names and even mailboxes for digital
fakes right
synthetic personal data helps fraudsters
to apply for things like loans they
receive bank cards using the states they
participate in trading on cryptocurrency
and options exchanges or they could even
sell fraudulent courses
and with this type of fraud there's
usually no clearly defined victim so
digital identities remain undisclosed
for a very long time now if you're
seriously concerned about the security
of your data there are a few things you
can do specifically services you can use
there's identity guard identity force
and id shield now for a subscription fee
these services scan popular hacker sites
on the clionet and the dark web they can
find stolen social security numbers
report database leaks with passwords and
even track social activity that is
conducted on your behalf such services
can identify synthetic identity theft
from individual pieces of your
information
and yet perhaps only they can protect
against the exact cloning of your
digital identity
[Music]
now the theft of digital profiles is
effectively the most technologically
advanced method of
well using personal data fraudulently
you remember that i told you about
search engines and large networks and
how they can distinguish you from
millions of other users just by your
digital fingerprints
i'm talking about the characteristic
features of your computer your operating
system your browser your online behavior
your geolocation and even the
characteristic patterns that you leave
behind
if you don't know what i'm talking about
then maybe you haven't seen our video on
digital fingerprints but no worries it's
eternally on our channel so take a look
after this video similar digital
fingerprint tracking systems used by
large banking systems
online stores or even crypto exchanges
and they basically compare your digital
footprints your behavior and the nature
of your payment transactions and if they
have reason to suspect that another
person is trying to use your card let's
suppose this transaction is from an
unrecognized computer from another
country it's for something unusual
perhaps then the suspicious payment will
be rejected in fact there are over 100
parameters that are analyzed to
ascertain authenticity in this sense and
yet according to juniper research losses
from online payment fraud will reach 43
billion dollars in 2021. but i suppose
the big question here is how are
scammers managing to pull off these
elaborate scams are they in coats with
the banks well no not at all they just
frequent these digital supermarkets
where you can literally buy a digital
clone of a real person
look
this one of the shadow exchanges
genesis store it has over 50 000 digital
clones in its database now the price of
these clones is determined by the
completeness of the data so a clone can
cost both five dollars and also two
hundred dollars the most expensive ones
come complete with an online banking
password and the cheapest ones well they
include access to a couple of social
networks or web services now this
effectively distinguishes genesis from
sites where user data was previously
sold where sets of usernames and
passwords or credit card numbers were
literally listed
and here you can buy a complete clone
the browser plugin actually allows you
to download the purchase data in just
one click and then the attacker can only
use a proxy server to simulate network
activity from some selected location
to be honest such digital slave markets
are a serious challenge for anti-fraud
systems like the one that we offer at
some sub therefore more and more
services resort to video identification
in fact there's actually a compulsory
feature with verification in places such
as germany estonia and also lucentine so
look if someone steals your digital
identity you're faced with some serious
issues according to itrc data 55 of
people who faced personal data theft
were forced to actually leave work
44 lost the opportunity to find
employment and 29 actually ended up
seeking state assistance financial
troubles in this sense can last for
months or even years you'll have to
restore your credit score over time and
actually convince the employees of the
tax administration that you weren't
complicit in hiding illegal sources of
income
ruined investment accounts can put an
end to your children's education and
deprive you of a decent pension later in
life
moreover if you encounter a difficult
case expert advice and legal costs can
actually undermine your financial
well-being and this goes without
mentioning the emotional consequences
which are not so obvious but are also
very pressing just imagine that on your
behalf under the guise of your photos
scammers deceived other people maybe
your friends or family your reputation
can be damaged irreparably the trust of
friends and colleagues may actually
never be regained even too much media
attention can damage your career and
finally remedyless damage can be done to
your health not only your physical
health but also your mental health
imagine that you spend several months
behind bars on charges of
major financial fraud it's unlikely that
you're going to return to freedom in the
same state of mind
and now remember about the probability
of medical errors if your medical
history is combined with that of another
person i mean
you've got to be careful
the techniques of scammers are
developing as rapidly as our digital
technologies are protection systems can
always be used against their creators
this race will continue and to leave the
race means to lose anyway my name is
bradley peake and i'd like to personally
extend my genuine gratitude for your
gallantry in this gallop across the
glimmering gracious goalscapes and the
grubby and galvanized growling growths
of the online jungle so i will
personally see you in the next video
thanks for joining us
[Music]
you